como que ya salí como que pasa como no
me avisaste perdón les pido disculpas es
que estoy compenetrado estaba hablando
con un amigo sobre los refranes estoy
estoy obsesionado con el tema de los
refranes que si tienen que ver o no y te
generan creencias a ver para que me
presten atención para que me entiendan
no hay mal que por bien no venga por
ende si vos quieres cumplir tu objetivo
te no sé si se tiene que ir mal primero
te tiene que ir bien te tiene que ir mal
te tiene que ir bien que te quiero
primero el mal o el bien y otro o saber
si me entienden con este a caballo
regalado no se le miran los dientes te
tiene que gustar todo lo que te regalan
o sea que te obligan a mentir vos me
estás regalando algo que a mí no me
gusta y te tengo que decir si me encanta
te están obligando a la mentira y hace
un montón de refranes que nos van
generando creencias que ahora tengo uno
ahora tengo uno que es el tau que es el
refrán de remera es el que te podría ser
la teacher como dicen en panamá una
remera negra frase blanca para ir al
boliche a la discoteca el que dice
es poder bomba no querer el poder es el
refrán que maximiza el querer y que dice
que si no crees lo vas a lograr tener y
para colmo en esta era de la modernidad
donde él quiere que está teniendo tan
buen marketing tienes tan buena prensa
vos te metes en las redes sociales y lo
primero que empezás a observar
son los gurús de la felicidad que dicen
sí que es poder sí pero después tenés
que querer y vas a poder lo vas a
obtener y hace un montón de refranes y
frases positivistas obvio prohibido
estar mal esas frases positivistas que
hasta a veces empalagan y por eso por
eso hoy les voy a contar una noticia
escuchen este dato el 80 por ciento del
éxito en las personas se debe a partir
de las emociones tiene que ver con lo
emocional existe un 20% que ya depende
de algo más analítico muchos lo
denominan tiene que ver con la suerte
por eso el querer es tan importante a la
hora de lograr un objetivo pero tenemos
que entender que no es suficiente es por
eso que yo
en esta conferencia les voy a contar por
qué querer no siempre es poder eso no
siempre es lo que yo denomino la verdad
incómoda' lo que nuevo mucho nos gusta
escuchar y hoy les voy a entregar un
método que se divide en tres partes en
las cuales les voy a contar cómo lograr
cumplir objetivos
la primera parte del método por supuesto
el querer la importancia que tiene
querer algo y hay dos maneras de querer
existe la motivación y existe el
entusiasmo de qué trata la motivación la
motivación es cuando perseguir algo
estar nuevos perseguir una zanahoria
esta expresión de una zanahoria que más
allá del dominio al que pertenezcas la
podemos llamar aumento de sueldo algún
premio más vacaciones e inconvenientes
que te quitas la zanahoria te de rivas
no tenes a que perseguir en cambio ese
entusiasmo en lo que yo comparo con
éramos con sentirte enamorado es ese
fuego interno que empezás a tener lo que
te hace estar nervioso lo que te hace
estar de buen humor lo que te genera
tensión te hace transpirar bueno cuando
sentirse ese fuego interno significa que
estás
algo pero claro no sólo basta con sentir
que lo que eres hay que ponerle nombre a
lo que querés y para colmo entiendo que
es difícil porque si lo buscas en google
estimo que debe ser de las pocas cosas
que busque que google o cualquier
buscador no te dicen que quiero
miren los invito a viajar un poquito en
el tiempo
yo soy de mar del plata es una ciudad
que queda a 400 km de buenos aires es
una ciudad que tiene mar donde tengo mi
familia tengo todos mis amigos a los 20
años a los 20 años tuve el coraje de
pararme enfrente de mi papá y decirle
papá
me voy a estudiar a buenos aires
claro más de uno de ustedes debe estar
diciendo hoy que tiene de yo hay acá esa
frase
claro porque ustedes no conocen a mi
papá mi papá es esa persona que desde
hace años había tenido la ilusión de que
su hijo criar a su hijo que estudie su
hijo y que ese sea su futuro socio yo a
mi papá con esa decisión le estaba
matando la ilusión de tener el socio que
siempre había soñado es por eso que
claro cuando elige papá me voy a
estudiar a buenos aires se le empezó a
transformar la cara se le empezó a
transformar la cariño por las dudas
empecé a hacer marcha atrás como que te
quieres ir a estudiar a buenos aires si
papá si así fue que me empecé a abrir la
puerta de casa me empecé a escapar y
claro 20 años argentinos un poco
canchero en asome la carita y dije
y te aseguro que algún día hasta me van
a apagar por hablar ahí es que cierro la
puerta y escucho un boom del otro lado
dije uy no sé si fue un zapatazo no sé
si fue el control remoto pero algo pasó
del otro lado por las dudas ese es el
día de hoy que yo trabajando me al
triunfo [ __ ] del otro lado de la puerta
de mi casa
así fue que viajé a buenos aires a la
gran ciudad empecé a estudiar
empezó a estudiar mi carrera de
marketing después empecé a estudiar
algunas habilidades blandas siempre fue
muy curioso para no aburrirme también y
en uno de los programas que comencé a
estudiar en la universidad católica
argentina
un día dos socios dos personas grandes
me dicen que queremos invertir en vos
y fue el momento en el que me hicieron
dos grandes preguntas
a vos que te gusta y aquí te dedicas
así tan sencillas como suenan esas
preguntas yo no tuve la respuesta
automática no les pude responder
enseguida yo me dedicaba a la
gastronomía en ese momento pero como no
lo sentía mi propósito no se lo pude
responder y así fue que me obligaron a
pensar y les dije saben que a mí me
apasiona agregarle valor a las cosas
me encanta poder cambiarle los momentos
a las personas y así fue que a partir de
una pregunta empecé a encontrar una gran
respuesta pasó el tiempo termine ese
programa y me llaman de la universidad
católica
mariela nunca me voy a olvidar y dice
hola gaita como estás quieres seguir
estudiando otra gran pregunta a la cual
ver de manera automática casi le dije
que no fue una de las primeras veces que
me atreví a decir que no y le dije marie
esta vez quiero ser profesor
y así es que entiendo que vuelve poder
poner nombre a lo que quieres a partir
de grandes preguntas y para colmo te
ofrezco un 'bonus track' el cómo validar
si lo que querés está bien
y por supuesto es con otra gran pregunta
voz a lo que querés te sentirías
orgulloso y contárselo a tus hijos el
día de mañana
ya les conté la primera parte de la
fórmula es el querer quedan dos partes
la segunda es el confiar aparte por
supuesto de ese 20% el confiar es la
parte en la que tiene que realizar tu
autoanálisis entender si lo que quieres
es sincero o está haciendo parte de un
capricho recordemos que las personas
podemos crear muchas cosas pero muchas
se escapan a nuestro radio de acción es
el momento en el que te vas a dar cuenta
dónde estás hoy y a dónde quieres llegar
que necesitas estudiar qué herramientas
vas a tener que incorporar porque
recordemos que la vida es un recorrido
en el cual tenemos que ir construyendo
y claro que es importante entender
también que lo que quieres
tiene que ser realizable más allá de que
sea un gran sueño tienes que entender
que lo podés cumplir te la tenés que
creer para no cruzarse con un gran
enemigo que puede surgir en el recorrido
que es la frustración la frustración es
aquel asesino de sueños es cuando vos a
los fracasos no los vas pudiendo
administrar porque fracasar lógico que
es parte del recorrido pero la
frustración es no saber administrar esos
fracasos
y ya vamos cuando vamos ocho minutos y
medio de charla y más de uno me habrá
visto las varitas dice y para qué tiene
la varita gaita en la mano vas a hacer
magia y no mago no soy la voy a utilizar
para lo siguiente voy a hacer un
diagrama y en este diagrama les voy a
explicar qué grado de protagonistas
estamos siendo cada uno de nosotros en
nuestras miren lo rojo tiene que ver con
tu nivel de entusiasmo ya se lo dije lo
importante que es estar entusiasmado
cuánto lo que eres y lo amarillo es el
nivel de preguntas que te estás haciendo
cuán curioso está haciendo con la
realidad si vos sos muy poco rojo en el
poco entusiasmo y sos poco preguntó
consideró que estás en el cuadrante del
negativo con ese negativo el presi
mental que todo le dice que no no no es
difícil es que se paraliza muy fácil es
de esas personas que ya esto ya está
seguro que son de los que se levantan a
la mañana y andan diciendo a ver a ver a
quién le puedo [ __ ] la vida hoy a quién
le voy a voltear un sueño espero que no
haya ninguno ha sido el otro lado bueno
te pones un poquito más amarillo te
pones más preguntón y acá es cuando se
es el gran espectador
el espectador de la vida aquel que ve
todo como un cine y yo digo que claro
sabe mucho porque es muy preguntón tiene
poca acción tiene poco entusiasmo
insisitido que es aquel que nació para
ser gerente el que dice lo que hay que
hacer pues te pones un poquito más rojo
que aumenta tu entusiasmo y es cuando te
convertirse en el caprichoso porque
conoces muy poco cuestionas muy poco la
realidad es que fijamos al idiota
entusiasmado en cambio cuando logras
encontrar la unión entre lo muy rojo y
lo muy amarillo que se forma exacto que
lo hicieron el naranja el famoso
cuadrante naranja y de qué se trata es
cuando logras ser protagonista en tu
hija
y por supuesto un día si a mi cuadrante
naranja entendí que había llegado un
objetivo fue el día que me llamaron por
teléfono otra vez de la universidad
católica argentina una universidad en la
cual nuestro actual papá francisco llegó
a ser rector me llaman por teléfono
inician en julián y queremos ver de
manera urgente tenemos una propuesta
para hacerte no vas a ser profesor te
queremos proponer que seas director y me
encontré con la gran oportunidad que los
ojos me empezaron a hablar y me nublé me
nublé yo sólo sabía que me habían
propuesto ser director tenía tres meses
para preparar mi primer curso de ventas
y así llegar a ser el director más joven
de la universidad católica argentina de
su escuela de negocios el tiempo pasó el
tiempo pasó y claro yo me sentía en ese
cuadrante naranja ya era director y ahí
es cuando volvió a entender que claro
eso no había saciado mi hambre al
contrario lo había potenciado yo quería
más es cuando empiezo a comparar la vida
con una carrera de base nos vamos
saltando obstáculos
cuando vos salta es un obstáculo ya que
desear al útil lo querés volver a saltar
somos in corpore inconformista las
personas y eso es sensacional tenemos
que ser muy curiosos y no ser
no ser conformistas con ese gran
cuadrante naranja
y así es que llegamos a la tercer parte
del método hablamos del querer y
hablamos del confiar y ahora llegamos a
la tercera parte lo que creo que es
innegociable lo exponencial del método
en practicar practicar practicar
practicar lo que es tu gran detrás de
escena lo que nadie ve es el gran
esfuerzo que vos hacéis lo que transpira
tu estrés lo que hasta dejas de dormir
lo que nadie ve y para colmo claro más
de un negativo más de un espectador
pasará y mira qué suerte que tiene como
la pego como aquí decimos como acá
decimos en la argentina claro porque el
nadie ve tu esfuerzo y ahí es cuando te
invito a generar tu gran indicador
cuanto más se escuchen cuanto más se
escuche que dicen que la pegaste que
tiene suerte significa que te está yendo
muy bien
por eso practicar entendamos que es
innegociable se entendimos las tres
partes del método primero lo tenemos que
querer y muy fuerte es importante
muchísimo es el 80 por ciento de la
fórmula después lo tenemos que creer
tenemos que confiar en nosotros tenemos
que entender a dónde vamos tenemos que
sentir que lo merecemos y el tercer paso
el tercer paso el método es el practicar
practicarlo innegociable
es este método que se les ofrezco para
que ustedes puedan cumplir sus objetivos
de manera simple de manera simple
pero saben qué
es interesante y cierto es muy
interesante este método pero nada nada
de esto hubiese sucedido si se hundía no
tenía una conversación
yo estaba estudiando está en mi carrera
de marketing y estaba trabajando en una
multinacional era la multinacional
trabajo soñado me habían entregado a los
seis meses el premio al mérito ya la
revelación mis propios compañeros
estaban por tener un ascenso récord y
así fue que como lo hacía cada 23 meses
mi mamá viajó a visitarme a buenos aires
nació el nuevo protagonista en la
historia mi viejita mi mamá una gran
protagonista de mi detrás de escena
fuimos a comer al mediodía como era mi
ritual era mi costumbre locales que
venían mis papás a visitarme a buenos
aires los llevaba a almorzar cerca de mi
trabajo a la mejor parrilla del barrio
de belgrano así fue que estábamos en un
mediodía excepcional un sol radiante
empezamos a comer y mi mamá me miró a
los ojos
de esa manera que sólo una madre lo sabe
hacer
ella me miró a los ojos y entretanto
hablar mío me detuvo
me agarró la mano y me dijo julián
bueno estás bien
apretó el botón de las preguntas a
través la gran pregunta bueno estás bien
así fue que la mira a los ojos y el
genoma no estoy logrando lo que
realmente quiero hoy no estoy trabajando
por mis sueños estoy trabajando para ver
para el sueño de otro
y de una manera muy sencilla con una
frase muy simple
fue que ella me dijo julián
o sea es cuando realmente te vas a dar
cuenta que estás luchando por lo que vos
querés el día que te puedas parar
enfrente de tu pared y puedas elegir de
qué color pintarla
ese va a ser el día que vos te sientas
libre y te vas a dar cuenta que estás
trabajando por lo que vos querés
por eso mi invitación para todos ustedes
además de entender el método que tenemos
que querer que no siempre es suficiente
porque tienen que confiar tenemos que
practicar la invitación es que a partir
de hoy va a ser en busca de su pared
para poder elegir de qué color pintarla
muchísimas gracias